- Hello, and welcome to
Khan Academy Live SAT.
I'm Eric, I'm an SAT tutor
and one of the SAT experts
here at Khan Academy.
I'm so excited to be with you today
to talk through SAT Reading.
Now if you've joined one
of our past live streams,
you'll notice that today's live stream
looks a little bit different,
and that's because our
amazing videographer Felipe
is out today, but so
that means we're using
a bit more of a homemade setup.
And so you'll actually get to see me
switching back and forth
a little bit between screens,
and so you get a peek behind the scenes.
And hopefully, there won't
be any tech glitches,
but if there are, just
you know, bear with me,
and we'll get those resolved.
And so like I said, today's
topic is SAT Reading,
and so I'm just gonna
give you a quick overview
of what we're going to cover today
before we get straight into the content.
Time to share my screen here,
and so, for today, today's
class like I mentioned,
the topic is SAT Reading,
and we're gonna cover a lot
of different topics here.
And next week, we will cover SAT Writing,
and it'll be at the same time,
so Tuesday at 7:00 p.m.
Eastern, 4:00 p.m. Pacific.
It'll be the third and
final part of our series.
And last week, in case you missed it,
we had a SAT Math class.
And if you missed that, don't worry,
just head to our Khan
Academy YouTube channel
and you can find the recording there.
But, like I mentioned,
today's all about SAT Reading,
and that's what we're here for.
And so, let's scroll
through and you'll see
the schedule for today's class.
So the first 10 minutes of class,
I'm gonna go through two things.
The first is the rephrase
and predict strategy.
And this is a proactive
strategy that you can use
to tackle SAT Reading questions.
The second topic I'm going
to cover is time management.
And I'm gonna walk through some
of the most common questions
I get when it comes to time
management and pacing yourself,
and not running out of time
on the SAT Reading section.
Next up, I'm gonna work
through a real SAT
Reading passage together,
and then we'll do some Q&A, and wrap up.
At the very end we'll answer
some of your questions
and also share a Khan Academy badge.
So I'll stop sharing then for now.
And so that's what we
have planned for the day.
There's a lot to get into,
and so let's jump straight
into the first reading strategy
which is all about the
rephrase and predict strategy.
So, share my screen again.
And so, the reason we're talking
about this strategy is for a few reasons,
and so let's think
through these questions,
and let me know if any of
these sound familiar to you.
So have you ever read the answer choices
in a SAT Reading section
and thought to yourself,
well, all of these look good,
and it could be any of them.
Or maybe you get it down to two choices,
but then pick the wrong one.
So maybe you've got it down to A or C,
but then you sometimes pick the right one,
sometimes pick the wrong one.
Or maybe you run out of
time in the reading section.
And so these things I've all,
I've definitely experienced
all of these things myself,
and a lot of students have
been in this situation.
And so that's why this
rephrase and predict strategy
can really help address these situations.
And so what is this strategy?
Well, this strategy is all about coming up
with your own answer to reading questions
before you look at the answer choices,
and this is really important.
And the reason you want to hold off
on looking at the answer choices
is that one, it's lots of
information to take in,
and two, perhaps most importantly,
it can be distracting.
And so it can sometimes lead you,
and influence your
interpretation and understanding
of the passage before
you have a good grasp.
And so you know, I like to call this
the the rabbit hole effect here,
and you don't want to be
led down the wrong path.
And so the two parts to this
strategy are one, to rephrase,
and so this involves reading the question,
but covering the answer choices.
And then if possible rephrase the question
into a how, what, or why
question to simplify,
and make it easier to understand.
The next part in this strategy
is to predict, and this involves
reviewing the relevant
parts of the passage,
and predicting the
answer in your own words.
And once you have this answer,
you can then uncover the answer choices,
cross out the choices that don't match,
and then select the
choice that best matches.
And so this converts
the SAT Reading question
into more of a matching question.
So if you already have something in mind,
it allows you to put these two things,
what you have in mind,
and compare it with the answer choices
that you have on the SAT Reading test.
And once it's a matching exercise,
most students find it
easier and faster, as well.
So we'll get plenty of time
to practice this later today,
but for now, I'm gonna
move on to time management,
and we're going to work
through some of the most common
time management questions that I get.
And so, move your gaze to the
bottom of the screen here,
and we'll walk through these
questions one at a time.
So the first question is
should you read the questions
or the passage first?
And if you have an answer,
go ahead and type that in,
and you know, feel free to share that
with others who are
watching the live stream.
So should you read the
questions or the passage first?
Well, I would recommend that,
well, it actually kind of, is up to you,
so you want to do what works for you,
but I would say that
scanning the questions
can help focus your attention
as you read the passage.
And say you have trouble
running out of time
on the reading passage, it
can be particularly helpful
because maybe you realize, you know,
I won't be able to read
through the whole passage.
I won't be able to
answer all the questions,
but maybe I can hone in
on the easier questions
and do those.
And so, you wanna do what works for you,
but I would encourage you
to try scanning the questions
first to see how that feels.
Try reading the passage
first, and do what works best.
Okay, next question,
should you answer all
reading questions in order,
or can you jump around?
I want to say this is within the passage.
So say you have a passage
and you have 11 questions,
should you answer all
reading questions in order,
or can you jump around?
You can absolutely jump around,
so jump around to your heart's content,
as long as you keep track of
the questions you've skipped.
And so, what that means is
say you skip number 17 and 18,
you'll just want to star
these in your test booklets,
so that you remember to go back.
And the reason you want to jump around,
well, we'll get to that in just a second,
but it's absolutely okay to jump around
within the SAT Reading
section within a passage.
Next up, next question,
should you do the easy
or harder reading questions
first as you go through?
Should you do the easy or
harder reading questions first?
So you definitely want to
do the easy questions first,
and that's because all questions
are worth the same number of points.
So it could be the
hardest reading question
in the whole section,
it's worth the same amount
as the easiest question on the SAT.
Furthermore, answering
the easy questions first
can help with time management,
and also help you better
understand the passage.
So maybe you've read the
passage and you're still,
you've got some question marks,
and you're not quite
sure you've understood,
well, these easier questions can help you
break down the passage
into its individual parts,
and then build your
understanding of the passage.
Now what do easy questions
sometimes look like?
Well, easy questions tend to be,
now this isn't always the case,
but they tend to be more specific.
And what I mean by more specific
is that they'll have a
line reference in them.
So line eight indicates,
and so it'll tell you exactly
where in the passage you want to look.
Whereas the harder questions,
and this, you know, again,
doesn't apply in all cases,
but harder questions tend to be broader,
and they might ask you
to compare and contrast,
and so, those questions tend
to take a little bit longer.
And so, if I have a choice, I
tend to leave those for later.
Okay, so a few more time
management questions here.
So should you jump between
questions for different passages?
Jump between questions
for different passages?
So I'm saying you have
passage one and passage two,
is it okay to answer some
questions in passage one,
and then some questions in passage two,
and kind of go back and forth?
If you have a hunch go ahead
and type that into the comments there.
So my recommendation is no.
I would not recommend
jumping between passages,
and you wanna do your best
to answer all questions
related to a passage before moving on.
And the reason for that is that switching
tends to take your brain
a decent amount of time.
So in this process,
this process of switching back
and forth, is time consuming.
And if you sometimes have
trouble finishing the section,
you don't want to do anything
that's time-consuming
and takes away your time.
So this is different from
what I mentioned before,
so within the passage, within
a passage it's okay to jump.
Within passage is okay
to jump, okay to jump.
Great, now final question here,
if you're running out of
time, should you always guess?
If you're running out of
time should you always guess?
Answer is yes, you should
absolutely always guess
because there is no guessing penalty.
So even if you have five or 10
or however many questions left,
always go to your answer sheet
and bubble in your best guess
especially if, you know,
you have a minute left
or 30 seconds left, it's
always better to guess
so you have a chance at
earning that last point.
Now we'll do a quick review
of these time management questions,
but you have any questions,
go ahead and type those in the comments,
as I'll be answering a few
time management questions shortly.
So if you have questions,
go ahead and submit them,
and I'll get to those in a second.
So should you read the
questions or the passage first?
Again, this is do what works for you,
but scanning the questions can help.
Should you answer all
reading questions in order,
or can you jump around?
You should absolutely feel free
to jump around within a passage.
Should you do the easy or
harder questions first?
You should definitely
do the easy questions,
try starting there it can really help.
Can you jump between questions
of different passages?
No.
Should you always guess?
Yes.
And so, those are some of the most common
time management questions I get,
and for now I'm going to answer a few
time management questions
that you all have.
And so I'm going to flip back
here, stop screen sharing
that's some screen inception there.
So if you have other time
management questions,
go ahead and type them into the comments,
and I'll work through a few of them
before moving on to a
real SAT Reading passage.
So let's take a look.
Should you skip certain
questions altogether?
Now that's an interesting question.
I'd say I would encourage you
to scan through all of the
questions relating to a passage,
and then if you're running
particularly low on time,
in one question, you know, just looks like
it's going to take a
solid three, four minutes,
then in that case, it's
completely fine to say,
okay, I'm making a decision.
I'm gonna skip number 18.
And just make sure like I mentioned,
to note that you skipped that question,
so that on your answer sheet
when you're bubbling things in,
you don't accidentally mis-bubble.
So that's probably the
most important thing
you want to remember when
you are skipping questions
is that you want to mark
down in your answer sheet
where you've skipped these questions,
so you don't mis-bubble anything.
But you know, if you if
you're running low on time,
and you see a question that's going to be
really tough and time-consuming,
it's okay to skip it.
Let's see, is it better to skim or fully,
so is it better to skim
or fully read the passage?
So that's another great question,
and I would say that you'll
want to practice that,
and try a few approaches yourself.
So I like to read the whole passage,
and you know, be pretty
active as I go along
to mark down what this
paragraph is saying,
what the author's next point is.
But for some people
what they can do is skim
through the passage and look through
what are called the topic sentences.
And that's the first
sentence in each paragraph,
and that can be a quicker way
of gaining some understanding.
But I'd say, you know,
skimming the passage,
and hoping to get a large
number of the questions right
is gonna be difficult.
At some point, you will need to really
read in more detail and understand
what the author is saying
and their position on on the topic.
Let's see,
what do you do if you
don't understand a passage?
So there I would, again, go back to,
there a few things I'd recommend.
One would be to read
just the topic sentence
of each paragraph to get
a broad understanding
without getting too detailed.
Another approach that I mentioned
is to tackle some of the
easier questions first,
and those easy questions
will be more specific
to just certain parts of the passage,
and if you can digest that
smaller part of the passage,
it can often build up your understanding,
so that you understand
the author's main points,
and the broader passage itself.
So we'll have more time to
answer these questions later,
but for now I want to take
some time to work through
some real SAT Reading questions.
But like I mentioned,
as I'm working through these questions,
if there's something confusing,
or you want me to answer
a question that you have,
type in those questions along in the chat.
We'll be collecting those
questions all throughout,
and I'll do some more Q&A at the very end.
For now though, we're going to do
a real SAT Reading section,
and get to as many of
those questions as we can,
so you can see what these
strategies look like
within the context of a real passage.
So let's dive in.
Share my screen again, share.
Okay, so like I mentioned,
I like to take a look at
some of the questions first.
and just give a quick scan.
And I've changed the format here
just to make it easier for you to read,
but so let's take a scan
through these questions.
What main effect do the phrases
paradigm shift and tilt that equation
have on the meaning of the passage?
So that's a interesting,
we've got line eight here
and line 48 and 49.
Actually, let's bring this back in here.
So paradigm shift line
eight, tilt that equation.
So this one is specific,
but it also has two parts of the passage
that I need to look at.
So it might take a little bit of time.
Based on the passage,
what is the significance of
Jeffrey Bada's experiment?
So Bada is a name I
wanna pay attention to.
According to the passage,
the main problem with the
Miller-Urey experiment,
so another name I wanna pay attention to.
And then I've got two
pretty specific ones here
line 29 and line 44 about more vocabulary,
and words in context,
then we've got main objections
of Bada's conclusion.
And then, which choice
provides the best evidence?
So here, just from
scanning these questions,
I've honed in on a few
important parts of the passage
that I want to look at,
so line eight, line 48.
I have some names that I
want to pay attention to,
so Bada, Miller-Urey.
And then from this question,
I've picked up that there's
some back and forth here.
So there's some back and forth here,
but sounds like between scientists,
so we're talking about
conclusions and experiments.
And so I wanna look at
the the kind of arguments
that are being made here.
And so this is my quick scan of questions,
and now what I'll do is flip
over to the passage itself,
and do some active reading.
And don't worry we'll go back
to the questions in a sec.
But hopefully, you can see this clearly.
And what I mean by active reading
is that I will be underlining, and boxing,
and making comments and checks,
and happy faces and
smiley faces along the way
to help me understand
as I'm going through.
And so I'll start with the blurb here.
And so that, this is the blurb.
This passage is excerpted
from Douglas Fox,
Primordial Soup's On
Scientists Repeat Evolution's
Most Famous Experiments
by Scientific American.
So again, it's a science passage.
Let's take a read.
A Frankensteinesque
contraption of glass bulbs
and crackling electrodes has
produced yet another revelation
about the origin of life.
Okay, so that's my introduction.
We're talking about the origin of life.
The results suggest that
Earth's early atmosphere
could have produced
chemicals necessary for life,
contradicting the view that,
contradicting the view
that life's building blocks
had to come from comets and meteors.
So this is what's called a
topic sentence in the paragraph.
And so it tells me a lot about what
is gonna be ahead in the paragraph.
And what I've gleaned from this
is that Earth might have had the chemicals
necessary for life.
And we have a but word
here so contradicting
the view that life's building blocks
had to come from comets,
and so, that's important.
I like to circle these contrasting,
kind of hold on but not yet worked.
So, "Maybe we're over optimistic,
"but I think this is a paradigm shift."
Okay so that was that
line eight word there,
It says, chemist Jeffrey Bada,
whose team performed the experiment
at the Scripps Institute of Oceanography
in La Jolla, California.
Bada was revisiting the
famous experiment first done
by his mentor, chemist Stanley Miller.
Okay, so Miller that
was a name that I wanted
to pay attention to, so
I've got Miller and Urey,
used a sparking device to
mimic a lightning storm.
The experiment produced a brown broth
rich in amino acids, the
building blocks of proteins.
The disclosure made the
pages of national magazines.
Oh, so made pages of national magazines,
and showed that theories
about the origin of life
be tested in a laboratory.
So this seems to be like
a pretty positive outcome,
so I'm gonna add some pluses here.
And produced brown broth
rich in amino acids,
so I've got some amino
acids that are here.
Okay great, so let's
continue reading here.
Okay, here's another one
of those contrasting words.
So, but, anytime that comes up,
it's usually worth paying attention to.
The Miller-Urey results
were later questioned.
It turns out that the gases he used,
a reactive mixture of methane and ammonia,
did not exist in large
amounts on early Earth.
Scientists now believe
the primeval atmosphere
contained an inert mix of
carbon dioxide and nitrogen,
a change that made a world of difference.
Okay so, just to recap
here in the passage,
we have experiment by Bada up here.
So this is Bada,
and then we have Miller here.
And so initially we're
feeling pretty happy,
but then, now, we're feeling sad.
So change made a world of difference.
I'm gonna, well, I don't
know that it's sad yet,
but there's definitely a
kind of shift happening here.
So when Miller repeated the experiment
using the correct combo in 1983,
the broth failed to materialize.
Instead it created a colorless brew
containing few amino acids.
It seemed to refute a
long-cherished icon of evolution,
and creationists quickly seized on it
as supposed evidence of
evolution's wobbly foundations.
So seized was another one of those words
that we were asked about in the questions,
so I wanna star this there.
And so like it mentioned,
it seems like the experiment
did not go as well the second time around,
and then we have yet another but.
So, but, another shift
that's happening here.
Bada's repeat of the experiment,
armed with new insight,
seems likely to turn
the tables once again.
Bada discovered that the reactions
were producing chemicals called nitrites,
which destroy amino acids
as quickly as they form.
They were also turning the water acidic,
which prevents amino acids from forming.
Yet primitive Earth
would have contained iron
and carbonate minerals
that neutralized nitrites and acids.
So Bada added the
chemicals to the experiment
to duplicate these functions.
When he reran it, he still
got the same watery liquid,
but this time chock full of amino acids.
So this amino acids keeps coming up,
and so I'm gonna mark out
that this time he did have it.
And so now we've shifted back
to Bada's point of view here,
and I just want to note that
this had no amino acids here.
Just so I know that, okay.
I'll read a little bit more.
So, "It's important
work," Christopher McKay,
a planetary scientist at
NASA Ames Research Center.
"This move toward more realism
"in terms of what conditions
were on early Earth."
So important work, so this is positive.
Most researchers believe
that the origin of life
depended heavily on
chemicals delivered to Earth
by comets and meteorites.
But if the new work holds up,
it could tilt that equation.
So that is another one of the questions
that we were asked.
Is astrobiologist at Princeton,
"That would be a terrific result
"for understanding the origin of life,
"and for understanding the
prospects for life elsewhere."
Okay, and a little bit more, but,
another but, lots of buts.
James Ferris, a prebiotic chemist
at Rensselaer Polytechnic,
doubts that atmospheric electricity,
so not yet there's a bit
of a hold-on tone here,
could have been the only
source of organic molecules.
"You get a fair amount of amino acids.
"What you don't get are things
like the building blocks
of nucleic acids."
Meteors, comets or primordial ponds
would still need to
provide these molecules.
So Bada's experiment
could have implications
for life on Mars because the Red Planet
may have been swaddled in nitrogen
and carbon dioxide early in its life.
Bada intends to test this extrapolation
by doing experiments
with lower-pressure mixes
of those gases.
Okay, so that was a lot of
information, but as I zoom out,
don't worry about trying
to read it right now.
I just want you to look
at how many underlining,
how much I've underlined,
how much I've boxed,
and how much I've annotated this passage.
And that it takes some time,
but as you practice more and more,
you'll get faster at
reading while annotating.
And what this annotation does
is make it easier for you
to find the relevant information
once you go through the questions.
So now I've done that.
And now I'm going to bring
up the actual questions,
and we're going to step
through these one by one.
So I'm zooming in, making
sure you can read it here.
So what main effect do the
phrases paradigm shift,
line eight, and tilt that equation
have on the meaning of the passage.
So paradigm shift in line eight,
I'm gonna change colors here,
paradigm shift in line eight.
And so let's take a read here
before we jump to lines 48 to 49.
So you'll notice I haven't looked
at any of these answer choices.
I've gone straight from the
question to the passage,
and this is all about coming
up with your own answer
before you look at the answer choices.
So let's see, let's read some
of the context along here.
So maybe we're over-optimistic,
but I think this is a paradigm shift.
Um, contradicting the
views a paradigm shift.
Shift usually means that
there's a change going on.
So it sounds like there's
a change in our thinking.
And then lines 48 to
49, tilt that equation.
Lines 48 to 49 here, so
here I've starred this.
And so most researchers
believe the origin of life
depended on chemicals but
if the new work holds up,
it could tilt that equation.
That would be a terrific result
for understanding the origin of life,
and for understanding
prospects, so tilt that.
So if the new work holds up,
it could tilt that equation,
and so we're talking about beliefs here.
And so this again, is
reinforcing this fact
that there's a change in
beliefs that's happening.
And so my that's going to be my prediction
for question number one.
Oh, what's the main effect
that these words have on
the meaning of the passage?
And so the main effect I'm saying
is that it indicates a change
in the belief that's happening.
And so now I want to match this
against these answer choices here.
So A, they imply that
the accepted theories
regarding the origin of life
on Earth are groundless.
So groundless, that seems pretty strong
and it doesn't match my
prediction that it's these phrases
just indicate that there's
been a change in the belief
in what scientists believe.
They indicate that Miller's experiment
regarding the origin of life
on Earth has sparked a debate.
So I like this word debate,
so I'll leave a question mark here,
and I'll leave that in contention.
They suggest a shift in scientific thought
regarding the origin of life on Earth.
So that shift and scientific thought
So this is pretty darn close to a change
that I have in mind.
And so, we've got a change there,
and so I like that.
And then, so that one is, you
know, in the lead right now.
And then D, they signal that scientists
are now certain how life began on Earth.
So scientists are not certain.
There's still a lot of experiments,
and it seems like things are
going in a promising direction,
but we are not certain.
And so with that process of
elimination and matching,
I know that my answer
is going to be C, great.
So that was a early example
of how you can use the
rephrase and predict strategy
to come up with your prediction here,
and then match it with the answer choices.
And it's usually easier to match,
once you have a prediction in your mind
than to go in and hope that
of one of these will fit.
So for now I'm gonna do some quick erasing
just to make it easier later,
but that was answer choice C.
So bear with me, these are
some of the tech things
that I mentioned earlier.
Okay, so now I want to look
at question number two.
So based on the passage,
zoom in a little more,
the significance of
Jeffrey Bada's experiment
rests mainly on his success at,
so the significance of
Jeffrey Bada's experiment
rests mainly on his success at.
Okay, so now I wanna go
back to the passage again,
and look at the relevant parts
that relate to Bada and his success.
And so we have Bada here,
and we've got Bada here.
And so I'm almost using my notes as a map,
so I can jump directly to
where the relevant parts
are in the passage.
And so let's take a look, we've got Bada,
so results suggest that chemical,
Earth's early atmosphere could have
produced chemicals necessary for life.
We think this is a paradigm shift
and so this is creating life.
Okay, so that's some context there,
and then I've also got more
about information from Bada here.
So Bada discovered that the reactions
are producing nitrites.
Yet primitive Earth would
have contained carbonate.
Okay, so I'm just scanning now.
So Bada added chemicals,
and when he reran it
got the same watery liquid,
but it was chock full of amino acids
And so this is a success,
right so, he kind of proved
that amino acids came in,
and so that is successful.
And so based on this
reread of the passage,
the significance is really
that he was successful
in reproducing the amino acids,
and so that in an experimental setting.
And so, the significance is that he had
successfully produced
amino acids, one sec,
success with amino
acids, with amino acids.
So now let's see which
one of these matches here.
So confirming that the
production of amino acids
on early Earth was possible.
So that is amino acids was possible,
so that is a pretty close match.
Explaining the critical
function of nitrates
to the production of amino acids.
So that did support the production,
and the experiments, so
that is a maybe in my book.
Verifying the presence of
nitrites in Earth's atmosphere
as well as in comets and meteors.
So he didn't mention
these comets and meteors
when he reran the experiment,
and so it's not that he verified
that they were in them, so that is out.
Then tracing the development
of different types
of amino acids on Earth.
So not only have we not talked
about different types of amino acids,
but again my prediction is that
the significance comes from the fact
that he successfully
created these amino acids.
And so that is most like answer choice A.
Right, so now question number three.
According to the passage, the main problem
with the Miller-Urey experiment was that,
so the main problem with
the Miller-Urey experiment.
And so now I want to go through here,
and look through the
Miller-Urey experiment.
And look here, I've got Miller,
and then I've got more Miller here.
So I want to reread this,
and I'm looking for the problem
in the Miller-Urey experiment,
and I've got this but here
and at then this sad face,
because it's probably where
I need to pay attention.
So, but the Miller-Urey
results were later questioned.
It turns out that the gases he used
did not exist in large amounts.
Scientists now believe
that the new atmosphere
contained a mix of carbon
dioxide and nitrogen.
The change made a world of difference,
and then when he reran it, the
broth failed to materialize,
and so didn't work anymore.
And so it sounds like these results
were later questioned
because the gases he used
were kind of incorrect
given this new belief.
And so if I go back down
here to the questions,
the main problem was that
there was a new belief,
and new understanding about the gases,
about gases and then that meant that
when he used this new system
then amino acids did not show up.
So let's take a read here at number three.
According to the passage,
to these answer choices,
the results have never been duplicated
in subsequent scientific experiments.
So the issue is not that
they've never been duplicated,
and my prediction was that
there was a new belief
that made amino acids invalid,
and that original setup
didn't work anymore.
So it's not about duplication.
The discovery of new evidence invalidated
the method of analysis.
So new evidence is pretty much
syncs with new belief there,
is similar to belief,
and so invalidated the method of analysis.
And so, yep, it meant that
his original experiment
didn't work, so that's pretty close.
And then the conclusion
neglected to account
for the ambiguous nature of the results,
neglected to account for the ambiguous
nature of the results.
Nope, again it's not
matching my prediction
around the new belief,
and so I can toss that out there.
And then, the research
methods used in the study
were ineffective in a laboratory setting.
So this one also feels close.
The research methods used in the study
were ineffective in
the laboratory setting.
And so now we are at
that age-old crossroads
of having to answer choices left, B or D.
So which one do we think it is?
So maybe you suggested a
few things in the passage,
or in the chat,
but what I like to do is
go back to the passage,
and look at the evidence.
Because the correct answer
when it comes down to
50/50 things like this,
will always be supported by
more evidence in the passage.
So the main problem with
the Miller-Urey experiment,
and that's gonna be up here.
And so the results were later questioned,
there was this new belief,
and a change made a world of difference.
And so rerunning it
meant that he no longer
got the results he wanted.
And so to me the new belief is
really what makes it for me,
and there's more evidence to
support this in the passage.
So the discovery of new evidence
invalidated his original
experiment that you see up here.
And so answer is going to be B.
And because we just did that, which choice
best supports the answer
to the previous question?
Which choice best supports
the answer to the previous question?
Well we just looked at that up here,
and so this is really where
we wanna pay attention.
It turns out that the gases he used
did not exist and scientists now believe.
And so let's see which
answer choice matches that.
It turns out, and go,
so there's our answer,
and that was exactly the text we used.
So it turns out that the gases is he used
did not exist in large
amounts in early Earth.
So I'll do one more question,
and let's take a look here.
Let's see questions five through eight.
I'll move this passage over,
and look at that magic.
Okay, and so questions five through eight.
Let's take a look here.
As used in line 29, seized
on most nearly means.
so seized on line 29.
It seemed to refute a
long-cherished icon of evolution,
and creationist quickly seized on,
seized on it.
I'll zoom in here.
So Miller reran the experiment,
the broth failed to materialize,
we have no amino acids,
and creationists quickly seized on it
as supposed evidence of
evolution's wobbly foundations.
So it sounds like
creationists were pretty happy
about the experiments failure.
And so it sounds like they're
they're almost bragging
about the fact that the experiment failed,
and so that's my prediction for this word.
And so what we've got is bragging,
and so which one of these words
bragging about the evidence
matches this prediction
about bragging about the evidence?
So they embraced the evidence,
that is not the same connotation
or meaning as bragging.
Took advantage of the evidence,
that feels pretty close,
so we'll leave that in.
They caught the evidence,
so that is not the same
as bragging about it.
They grappled with the evidence,
so this almost means,
grappling is almost the same
as discussing the evidence,
or wrestling with it to
see you know if it's valid.
But they didn't really
discuss or wrestle with it,
it was more just about bragging,
and kind of saying, aha I've got you.
And so answer choice is going to be E.
So that was a run-through
of the practice reading strategies
and time management
strategies within the context
of a real SAT Reading passage.
Now as I went through it,
I, you know, took my time,
explained my thinking a lot more,
and so spent a little
bit longer per question.
If you're doing this
by yourself you would,
as you gain more practice doing this,
get faster and faster at this.
But wanna to call out
that some of y'all are probably saying,
huh, if you spent a lot
of time for a question,
you know, it's just for
the purpose of illustrating
how to use this strategy.
But as you practice at home
by yourself with a stopwatch,
with a timer, you'll really get faster,
and you'll be able to move
more quickly through this.
So now I'm gonna do a walk through,
how you'll get your badge,
and then I'll answer some final questions.
So to get your badge
look at the YouTube chat,
next to the live stream,
and there will be a link to the badge.
Once you click the
badge you'll be able to,
you'll be asked to log into
your Khan Academy account,
and then in the top right corner
is where you're going to get
a notification that says,
hey, you've got your badge.
And so click the link,
log in, get your badge.
Now finally I'm gonna
do some more questions and answers,
and so if you have a
question about anything
that I've covered go
ahead and type that in,
and I'll answer as many as I
can in the next few minutes.
So let's take a look.
How much time should
you spend on a passage?
Lots of questions around this.
So in this case, I would say a few things.
So within the reading section
there are a handful of
passages, and not only,
what I would encourage you to do first
is actually look through the passages,
and focus on the one that
maybe looks the easiest,
and prioritize the easier
ones over the hard ones.
And so that'll let you
one, just focus your time on the passages
that you know look the easiest
and most understandable,
but then I would just do the math.
And so you you'll know
that a reading section,
I think is, I don't want to misquote this,
but so look at how much
total time there is
in the total reading section,
divided by the total number
of reading questions.
Since there are 11 questions per passage
that should help you get an idea
of how much time to spend
on each individual one.
And so just do the division,
and that would be a good goal to aim for.
Let's see, how do you
improve your reading speed?
So another good question,
and sadly there's not
a silver bullet to this
other than practicing and reading a lot.
So it's not that you have to read
a million SAT Reading passages,
but the work that you're
doing in your English class,
and if you're reading a
novel or reading nonfiction,
will all speed up your reading speed here.
The only thing I might
suggest within the SAT context
is if you are running low on time,
to scan those topic sentences
at the start of each paragraph,
as that can give you a good
overview of the passage
without needing to read every single word.
Let's see, okay, for those
questions asking a point,
and then making you find the evidence,
do you read the evidence first,
or figure out the answer first?
So I would strongly encourage
that you figure out the answer first,
and what that will force you to do
is to go back into the passage
to the parts that are
relevant for the question,
evaluate the evidence yourself first,
and then as you come
up with your prediction
for the right answer, you
naturally make the connection
and you'll say in your head,
well, I think it's, you
know, the author's point is
because of this line right here.
And the power comes from when you can say
it's because of this line right here.
And when you combine those
you have not only the answer
to the first question,
but the because part, as
you're saying it in your head,
is the evidence and the answer
to that second part of the question.
Let's see, how do you practice
reading comprehension?
So I would say there are
the practice sections
within official SAT
practice on Khan Academy
are a great way to do it.
And so as you practice,
those sections have 11 questions each,
very similar to what
you'll see on the SAT,
the real SAT Reading section.
And I would just have a timer there,
so that you're simulating
the time pressure
that you'll actually experience.
And work through it at a good speed,
and try and make sure you're
doing it within the time frame.
Do you need to annotate?
How can you annotate that
much in the limited time,
and can you write in the test book?
So I would say annotate as much as you can
without really slowing
yourself down too much.
It's a bit of a compromise
that you're striking.
So if you read really fast,
you might be going too fast,
so that it's actually,
you you may not have
understood everything.
By annotating you slow down
and check for understanding at each place,
but I do understand
that the first few times
you're annotating it might
take a little bit more time.
So as you practice you'll get faster,
and you'll get faster at reading,
understanding, and annotating all at once.
And your final question,
can you write on the test booklet?
Absolutely, so mark that test booklet up
as much as you want,
and the more you mark it up,
the more hands-on you are, the better.
Let's see, how do you best
go about answering paired passages?
So great question.
So paired passages are a
really interesting beast,
and the way I would do that
is you have two passages,
right, passage A and passage B.
What you want to do is
answer read passage A,
answer passage A questions.
Read passage B, answer
passage B questions.
And then those questions
that ask you to compare and
contrast passage A and B,
those obviously require
the most understanding
across both passages,
and you want to save those for the end.
And so this goes back to
that time management tip
that I shared earlier that says,
you know, stay within a passage,
do all the questions related
to that first passage
before you shift to the second passage,
and then finally, the hardest questions
that cover everything you
want to save for the very end.
And so, I'll just do one more question
and then we'll wrap things up.
Ah, (laughs) wait we have one,
when is the next livestream?
That's probably a good one to end on.
So the next livestream is next Tuesday,
same time, so 7:00 p.m.
Eastern, 4:00 p.m. Pacific,
and we're going to cover SAT Writing.
And so that's gonna be all about grammar,
and kind of how important context is
within an SAT Writing
and language passage.
And so that'll be next
Tuesday, same exact time.
You can't make it don't worry,
we'll send out the recording,
but that's all I have for you today,
and hopefully you found this helpful,
and feel free to go back
and re-watch any of this
if you want to slow down and see a repeat.
But hope you found this helpful,
and hope to see you next
Tuesday at the same time.
Take care.